it's time for I've seen an unseen
segment with Raymond Arroyo where we
expose the big cultural stories of the
day they re kids being used as pathetic
political props no it can't happen well
at the end of ladies first in
restaurants and the power of faith at
d-day and beyond all right Raymond kids
have been starting starting to quiz
candidates on really complicated
constitutional matters they're not being
coached are they oh no Laura the kids
are popping up all of a sudden at these
political events here's Joe Biden
answering a kid from New Hampshire
yesterday watch do you think a pitchman
person should start how old are you I'm
not looking forward to an impeachment
process and I really mean it I think it
would be a gigantic distraction on
things that in fact we should be
focusing on getting done and the truth
of the matter is though that there is a
constitutional obligation my job is to
impeach him a different way beat him
nice we're changing the voting age to 11
why is he making a pitch to little kids
say the darndest day out that their
coach to say no he's not the only one
here's Pete Buddha judge responding to a
young girl after she asked how do you
beat Trump in 2020 you can't play his
game you know he's really mean and he
likes to call people names and if we do
it his way I think we're gonna live so
we have to change the whole game Laura
if they were teaching kids to be
literate or trying to build them up I
like but I know but they're demonizing
they're demonizing the opponent which is
what I thought was called bullying I
understand that politicians have
different arguments there their policy
let kids be kids for a while swimming in
the toxic soup of what we do what 11
year old is concerned about any of these
guys I'm glad Joe Biden's taking the
really tough questions because they're
shielding in from the press as it is but
they'll let those 11 year-olds atom
every there you go now I say goodbye
Laura to the chivalrous moments like
this at restaurants this is over mr.
Moore
yes it's a Lewis I'm Jeff Morse
this fireball there's my grandson David
yeah well I don't know about the
fireball part but grandsons true enough
I'm pleased to meet you both this is a
friend of mine Vivian ward rising for a
lady is apparently out now there's a new
trend it emerged last summer it's really
picking up steam now the website eater
says restaurants are saying goodbye to
soft sexism at Chicago's tide house
it's omitted the idea of ladies first
the staff has eliminated language like
ladies and gentlemen Phillipe Cavallari
and they no longer serve in order of
gender performance when you take the
fork and say pay attention to me what is
yeah I object to this and I'll tell you
why I find so repulsive men and boys
learn respect by doing things when you
rise when a lady enters the room when
you pull a chair for a lady it's showing
respect people want women to be
respected and they should be lets show
and teach men and young boys how to do
that
let ladies go first open the door and
pulled it you know what I do it one of
my son Dmitry were going into a
restaurant and he goes in and and I just
let the door closed and I wait outside I
said are you in mommy what happened you
didn't open the door for me said oh I'm
sorry but they learn it's kind of fun to
see the little kids do that but I'd
imagine if you if the waiter came over
and I said I'll have the hamburger and
I'll and then you just get waited on but
like I guess I'm a throwback that's my
problem
I agree now before we go during the
president's state visit to England there
was a lot of talk about faith and
sacrifice the fact that the president
chose to highlight the alliance with
Britain and what binds us at that first
state dinner Laura I think was
significant watch the bonds of
friendship forged here and sealed in
blood on those hallowed beaches will
endure forever our special relationship
is grounded in common history values
customs culture language and laws our
people believe in freedom and
independence as a sacred birthright and
cherished in herre
it's worth defending at any cost now
then today he invoked prayer the prayer
that FDR in tone as our men took these
beaches here at Normandy this is the
president at Plymouth they will lead
that blessings that's what the enemy is
strong he may hurl back our forces but
we shall return again and again and we
know that by thy grace and by the
righteous of our cause our sons will
triumph Lord not only FDR Eisenhower
invoked the blessing of the Almighty on
this noble undertaking and a lot of the
men who are buried behind us had little
Bibles and and and they're also Stars of
David on these on these the chaplains
having masks for them on the decks of
the ships before they deployed in
Normandy that God was certainly in the
air here and and you feel in him quoting
when he was quoting the FDR prayer
better than the mcclain Bible Church I
just thought that was a better comment
for trial I thought they were both good
but that was a good moment